[Musica]
ciao a tutti da un mesetto a questa
parte sto collaborando con infiniti ora
il catalogo di infiniti e molto molto
colposo vedere tutte le sue film ha
risvegliato in me dei dei ricordi di cui
non ho mai parlato con con nessuno ma è
da un mese a questa parte infatti che
non ha pace
piango di giorno che ancora notte mi
sveglio distrutto e il cibo erano più il
sapore di una volta ma forse arrivato il
momento di fare chiarezza
ora forse non tutti lo sanno ma in
passato ha fatto numerosi provini per
svariati film e non sono mai stato preso
e il motivo naturalmente rimane ancora
oscuro al grande pubblico ma purtroppo
per per il sistema
io ho conservato tutti i video delle mie
ambizioni e credo che sia forse arrivato
il momento di parlare e soprattutto di
mostrarvi come all'interno
dell'industria cinematografica la
meritocrazia non esiste
mandiamo i video ciao sono guglielmo
scilla e questo è il mio provino per
jurassic world
[Applauso]
[Musica]
si no
cazzo ma che muovono dio razzo chiama
l'amico tulips anonymus voleva mostro
porto il problema di 300 ok perfetto e
puoi metterti un po di profilo grazie in
curva un po le spalle ogni più solleva
la lancia incurvate ancora se qui per il
corpo traditore immagino no io allora
grazie grazie
e qui per il provino di mezzo al grey se
si può improvvisare qualcosa per portar
via
sì
[Musica]
di fare un'offerta che non poteva
rifiutare ok
proviamo a senza il cane perfetto per
questo nuovo dovremmo sapere secondo lei
cosa vogliono o no questa è facile
perché in realtà le donne vogliono una
super bowl è praticamente farebbero le
riprese così da non essere un certo
punto così colombo cm così così come sei
qui per la grande bellezza si è il mio
sogno lavorare con sorrentino interi o
ha portato un monologo drammatico di noi
ma facciamo un cambio d'abito
ok perfetto devo fare adesso un cazzo
prossimo questo è un provino video per
la parte di sauron brodo dove dias con
di maledetto merda non voglio fare un
gioco che cos'è i quattro cantoni e io
la briscola non la conosco ma un gioco
in cui morirai
ecco cazzo il lupo mangia frutta
pensatore il nostro tempo una volta ha
detto una frase molto azzeccata che io
posso anche morire un poco l'importante
è che la storia lascari mio e quando a
parlare sono i grandi non possiamo
solamente facendo un passo indietro non
ci vediamo nel prossimo video un
abbraccio
usiamo
[Musica]